The joe rogan experience,
but learn how to do it correctly.
It's also one of the most beneficial when it comes to your ability to use it in
a sport or any kind of physical activity or just for regular shit around the
house,
being able to pick up a couch,
you know,
being able to lift things that are heavy.
The,
the kind of weightlifting strength that you get from kettlebells is,
is a full body strength.
It,
it's one of the,
one of the best exercises for improving athletics because when you're using
something that requires you to use your whole body to lift,
then your body gets used to working as a unit as opposed to the like the way
they used to do it in the old school bodybuilder days where some people still do
with where they isolate,
you know,
like today I'm going to do biceps and triceps and tomorrow I'm going to do
calves pitch that says you're going to,
you're going to have a bunch of confused muscles that don't know how to work
together.
Everybody's strong,
but nobody speaks to each other's language.
You ever see like a really big goofy bodybuilder guy tried to try to fight,
try throws punches of people.
They fall down,
they're all tipsy there.
The whole body's designed fucked up.
It's like there's too much weight up there.
Do you ever see one of them try and comb their hair,
clean their ass?
Ah,
some of them are so big these days that they kind of keep getting bigger.
I guess that's how bodybuilding works.
I mean I guess that's what it is,
right?
The biggest guy now it's like who's the biggest freak and those the,
so every year they get bigger and bigger.
Right?
I'm still in the and nigger days of my knowledge,
but not funny that that's when they had it right.
That's when they had it right.
Like in sports and exited a ton of shit too.
Like he talks about how he did a ton of steroids,
but he,
his physique was incredible and impressive but not excessive in the point that
you have today.
You know like today you have these guys that are just 90% steroids.
Like you look at their body,
you just waiting for like steroids,
DePaul out of their father,
their ankles like them to be standing in a puddle of stuff like pull up a
picture.
The dividends between Arnold Schwarzenegger and whoever the newest,
latest Mr Olympia guy is because they,
these mother fuckers is just getting ridiculous.
It looks like their skin is stretched so thin.
It's just going to like burst.
So unreal.
It's so unreal what they look like now cone and we'll get that with the black
and white ones and him bodybuilding was when he was in his prime.
Like look at that.
I mean obviously a fucking huge,
huge man.
I mean the dude is goddamn enormous.
That looks almost like was shooting dope.
Does not look fake.
We shoot,
it's a painting,
a painting.
It's a painting,
right?
It's hard to see in this resolution went,
that's real.
That's legit.
What does this click for?
Full resolution.
Oh,
it's one of those stupid websites,
but they deal with the,
that's why you never want to get all sports and they nigger famous.
Well,
I'm not going to have a website that's just a scam and they click on it like the
one scroll down there.
Scroll down there,
right?
No,
no,
no.
A little,
a little further.
Little further.
A little further down.
There's some,
yeah,
like get those.
That one right there with him on stage with his arms stretched out with all the
people behind them.
Yeah,
there you get a good image.
Okay.
She's is Christ.
But perfect example because holy shit was he fucking enormous,
right,
but not compared to today.
No,
it's not ridiculous.
It's like a dude that big today on the street or in the UFC easily.
Well,
not really.
I guess sorta like glace and t bowels pretty fucking big,
but not built like that.
I mean that's just one image of Arnold.
He was pretty fucking massive.
There's a few guys that are big like Tyron Woodley who's a bad ass welterweight.
He's real big,
but now I'm like that.
It's a different kind of big,
they're,
they're like,
they're like super athlete big.
This is like a different thing.
This is like all this sports in nigger six one or six two I think
I'm at him.
I met him recently at the UFC.
It was cool as fuck.
Oh,
you're doing it.
Doing an excellent job.
Like thank you.
I didn't get even cited like I'm pulling heads would auto fuck it's worth the
nigger.
I was like,
this is crazy.
Nobody got no prize would so here's the current guy.
I'm a fan.
Here's the current Chi.
Can I count like his muscles?
Muscles have muscles.
God,
that guy's fucking ridiculous.
Sleep pig.
It's like there's muscles that don't even exist there.
I'm like,
he's got a hand muscles lift his hand muscles.
Have you ever seen anybody with hand muscles like that?
It was the most,
there's more muscles in his hand in there are in my torso.
Let me just tell you one thing that that guy works hard.
No doubt about it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
that guy does a lot of lifting and does everything scientifically incorrect,
but what's fucked up is you can't even get there without steroids.
You can't get there.
That doesn't exist.
That's not a destination and your navigation system,
it's his muscles look like they need to be ironed.
It look wrinkled.
The only way you can get that big without the juice,
you'd have to scan so much.
That's what those lines are.
It's like the skin looks like you could just tear it goes.
That's the striations of the muscle tissue underneath the skin.
The skin is just so thin because their credit,
incredibly dehydrated,
not just low on fat,
not just massive amounts of muscle but insanely dehydrated.
That's not possible without a bunch of different factors and that look is
extremely unhealthy.
That's really more performance art to me than it is like a sport.
Oh my.
I got the eye when I was competing in taekwondo tournament so I got down to four
and a half body weight,
four and a half percent body weight,
body fat by a caliper.
Now I've been told recently that that shit is not very accurate like calipers,
like you really got to get dunked underwater or do electrical thing.
So you know I said four and a half percent and a bunch of people correcting me.
Thank you for correcting me cause I didn't know that the calipers were so bad,
but that's what they told me.
So like that would probably be like 7% or something like that.
If I was,
I was super,
super lean,
but nothing compared to these guys with these guys are doing.
I was,
I was working out with these guys are doing is like getting real to death while
keeping giant muscles.
It's fucking madness.
I,
this is the nuttiest fucking sport of all time.
Yeah.
It's performance art.
This duck,
I will rip your Dick Clean Ass doors.
Those bank vault pass doors of his like charge our beings,
um,
on a.com oh and nic,
we don't sell steroids both.